this video is brought to you by nano
creators of virtual reality tools for
immersive molecular visualization and
interaction follow the link in the video
description to download nano man explore
molecules yourself
all right charge restructure so we
already mentioned that tertiary
structure refers to the overall fold the
3d structure otherwise known as the
native conformation and of course this
includes mainly the key thing to keep in
mind is the side chains right
interactions between the side chains and
that could be hydrogen bonds hydrophobic
interactions electrostatic interactions
and disulfide bonds disulfide bridges
relationships between secondary
structures which includes motifs or
super secondary structures and also the
involvement of any prosthetic groups
like like heme and hemoglobin okay so
when it comes to tertiary structure
support understand one thing that I want
to mention is that there are two types
of proteins okay there are there are
fibrous proteins which just the skinny
on them the long story short is that
with them the polypeptide does not fold
back upon itself these are rod like
proteins and examples include collagen
elastin keratin they're all meant for
structural support they're kind of like
long fibers little rods and they're
there their purpose they serve a
structural purpose okay the other type
of protein which is most proteins are
globular proteins and most proteins or
enzymes are globular proteins okay there
they're literally exactly what they
sound like they're they're little globs
okay the polypeptide does fold back on
itself so you don't get this long rod
like fiber instead you have this long
string that eventually folds into some
sort of glop kind of like a ball compact
and spherical most of them are water
soluble because they end up in I mean
where as humans and other animals there
were like 70% water and so almost any
protein that's in our bodies is
dissolved in an aqueous environment and
so almost all these these globular
proteins are water soluble or
hydrophilic okay
some examples include hemoglobin
myoglobin and pretty much any enzyme you
can think of okay there are some that
exist in nonpolar environments and thus
their surfaces are
nonpolar okay and there are
lipid-soluble
those are there are a few of them like
that okay okay so let's talk about the
interactions that stabilize tertiary
structure and we'll start with
hydrophobic interactions so let's scroll
down here so when it comes to
hydrophobic interactions this is
basically that when nonpolar or
hydrophobic portions or side chains
basically remain buried in a proteins
interior not exposed to the hydrophilic
environments so if you imagine a protein
as like a ball in fact imagine it kind
of like an orange okay
an orange has its peel which covers its
surface and it has the fruity portion on
the inside that fruity portion is not
exposed to the outside so long as that
orange is not cut open but if you
imagine a slice of an orange looks kind
of like this you have the slice you have
the peel right there and then you have
the the fruity interior okay and the
fruity part on the inside so if you
imagine a protein to kind of be like an
orange the surface is exposed to the
outside
the air okay and it with proteins that
surfaces exposed typically to water and
so what ends up happening is that the
the side chains that have the polar side
chains tend to hang out sort of on the
exterior to interact with the polar
water environment okay whereas the
nonpolar or hydrophobic portions tend to
be buried inside the the protein not
really exposed to that that water on on
the outside okay and that's for most
globular proteins let's take a quick
look at the interior of this hemoglobin
if we look inside here some of these
portions are highlighted blue whereas
the rest of it is red the blue portions
I specifically highlighted because they
are hydrophobic residues so let's
actually go inside here so we can see
here these portions are blue is the
leucine here and this is also leucine
over here and if we go inside we can see
some more blue pores
the interior here for example we've got
an alanine also hydrophobic and over
here we got another leucine so the point
is that all these hydrophobic residues
are on the interior of the protein and
that makes sense given that hemoglobin
is a protein that is dissolved in the
blood which of course is an aqueous
environment so the hydrophobic residues
don't want to interact with that aqueous
environment so they'll kind of bury
themselves in the the interior of this
protein right sort of away from the
water now there are some where the
opposite is true okay and on the surface
you have those nonpolar side chains
that's kind of the case for proteins
that are embedded in lipid soluble areas
namely membrane proteins because
membrane you have the it's a lipid
bilayer so it looks something like this
so you have these phospholipids and it
looks something like this
so this is a membrane here and so if you
have a protein that's embedded in here
the surfaces if I just draw this is like
a protein like in purple here if I have
a protein that's embedded in a membrane
then the portions here in this region
that I'm shading in here they're exposed
to that lipid soluble environment and
thus the surface the amino acids on the
surface of that protein would that are
interacting with that hydrophobic
environment are going to be nonpolar
amino acids nonpolar side chains so this
idea of like dissolves like is important
for how a protein folds and the overall
structure takes on okay so next up
hydrogen bonds so hydrogen bonds now in
this case we're talking about hydrogen
hydrogen bonds specifically that are
between the R groups or between the side
chains okay and so just to name a couple
examples of amino acids that have that
100 how did you bond a lot are the ones
with OAH groups so serine threonine and
tyrosine though they're not the only
ones asparagine and glutamine can can
hydrogen bond to certain extent with
their mi groups and their carbonyls and
nitrogen they're whatnot the point is
though that when we were talking about
hydrogen bonds as it when when it comes
to tertiary structure we're talking
about them between the R groups okay
between the side chains not between the
atoms to the backbone so it's different
from secondary structure or hydrogen
bonds because those are part of the
backbone not the hydrogen not the side
chains okay
so right here we've got for example a
glutamine and right next to it we've got
a lysine so both of these residues can
participate in a hydrogen bond and they
happen to be close enough to each other
that there may actually be a hydrogen
bond holding these two together and the
interaction is important sort of locally
holding this region together right but
you can imagine that I've actually
highlighted all the different areas in
this blue glowing highlight to basically
show the residues that can hydrogen bond
so there could be a lot of different
Vons holding this overall structure
together all right next up is uh
electrostatic interactions okay so let's
just attic interactions are just the
idea that charged polar groups will
either attract or repel so like charges
repel
while opposite charges attract okay so
if you have for example two ass partes
next to each other to a sports AIDS next
to each other you've got carboxyl group
their carboxyl group here these negative
charges they're gonna repel they're
gonna want to be kind of away from each
other okay they're not gonna come closer
to each other because they're like
charges however if you have an aspartate
next to a lysine and we have a carboxyl
group here and an amino group here then
that negative charge and that positive
charge are going to be attracted to each
other and they'll kind of come together
so here we've got two residues a
glutamate and a lysine included -
negative charge licensed positively
charged so these guys are attracted to
each other so they're gonna hold this
region of the protein together now if i
zoom back out all those residues that
are highlighted in blue are capable of
participating in electrostatic
interactions so basically maybe these
two are just sort of holding this local
region of the protein together but
there's a cumulative effect across the
entirety of the protein when it comes to
electrostatic interactions holding the
entire structure together okay and so
that's basically it when it comes to
electrostatic interactions just the idea
that charges will either attract or
repel okay and so again again we're
talking about the sidechain specifically
okay next up is that disulfide bonds
disulfide bridges so cysteine residues
near each other can form covalent bonds
covalent disulfide bonds okay so if you
have two cysteines next to each other
they have these Thyle groups these SH
groups and so what can happen is that
they can come together and form a
covalent bond
between them okay and that is the
disulfide bond or disulfide bridge
that's what that is okay now that's
important because that covalent bond
there that's hence these little stars
that's the only interaction as far as
tertiary structure that's actually
covalent the rest of these guys
hydrophobic interactions hydrogen bonds
electrostatic interactions are all non
covalent interactions okay
now that happens that forms that
disulfide bridge that forms forms in an
oxidizing environment
okay so there's an oxidation reaction
which will remove these hydrogen's to
give that disulfide bridge okay so here
we got the protein RNA a and anyway
we've got this disulfide bridge here
between 1640 and 1695 and this I thought
my bridge is important in holding the
entire protein structure together and
its entire protein of course made up of
just one polypeptide but this specific
that self at bridge is important holding
this localized region together as well
as being important to the overall
protein structure now now that we know
what holds together tertiary structure
just a quick note on what can actually
disrupt these different interactions
okay so when it comes to hydrophobic
interactions detergents detergents
disrupt hydrophobic interactions will
talk more about denaturation disruption
of the disruption of protein structure
later in another another video in the
series okay or hydrogen bonds they're
disrupted by heat or by molecules that
can hydrogen bond extensively and we'll
kind of see what that means later
electrostatic interactions
unless you're SATA contractions are
disrupted by pH changes because of
course pH changes will determine whether
or not certain groups are protonated or
deprotonated and that can have an impact
on whether they're charged or not and
what charge they have and that that's
going to of course impact whether groups
are attracting or
telling or attracting or repelling less
or more heavy metals having metals where
always metals are typically cations
right they're positively charged and
they basically are attracted to
negatively charged side chains and
they're repelled by positive charged
side chains okay disulfide bonds were
disulfide bridges they're disrupted by
reducing agents so reducing agents
basically get the reverse reaction to go
so if you had a reducing agent here that
disulfide bridge will break up into
those separate Thyle groups okay so
we'll talk a little bit more about about
protein denaturation later in the series
but I hope that video was helpful as far
as tertiary structure goes thanks for
watching